[Music]
hello i'm jen wilson senior programmer
with film independent and film
independent presents welcome to this f5
presents q a for the new film dilia's
gone by robert boudreau special thanks
to our lead sponsor the hifa and vision
media who hosts all our virtual
screenings and q and a's
and now please welcome director robert
boudreau hi robert hello
how are you
i'm good how are you thank you so much
for talking about
this film today
um i wondered
i wondered since we have a lot of
members of film independent that are
aspiring filmmakers
if you could talk about how you got
started
uh as a filmmaker
sure
um i mean i think i got started in uh
kind of the usual way on one hand and
that you know i i
started by loving film growing up and i
never really thought it was something
that i could actually do i thought it
was just something you kind of saw and i
came from
my parents were both uh professionals
and so i never really imagined i could
actually do that for a living and then i
kind of got exposed to the business and
i thought oh man this is like something
people actually do and so i started you
know i went to film school i went to
film school out west in vancouver at the
vancouver film school
and
uh you know made some film school shorts
and then i and then i went on to make
some other little short films ranging
from you know four minutes to
kind of 10 minutes and then i made kind
of like a calling card short film which
is like a 22 minute film which was shot
on super 35 at the time which was all
fancy
and then i made my first feature um and
that was you know 10 15 years ago and so
it was kind of just learning the craft
both through film school the theoretical
and the academic but then also just
making lots of shorts and just
learning on the fly so i think a very
typical
progression in that sense
so for this film
um
julia's gone it's based on a short story
by michael hamblin called caged bird
sing
what was it about this story that made
you want to adapt it and make it into a
feature
well i i kind of love the
um i i'm i grew up in a small town uh i
mean i moved when i was 18 or 19
whenever i go off to university but i've
always loved kind of rural noir as as um
as a genre and so i was attracted to
this
kind of midwestern small town american
rural noir
feel and so i love that aspect of the
story michael hamblin is is from uh uh
idaho and so he certainly
knows that that small town world very
well and so and i just loved lewis as a
character i thought on one hand he's
this you know flawed individual and in
the original short story he was actually
much older i made him younger um
in the adaptation but this idea of
there's a kind of almost like a
steinbecki and mice or men quality
to him where he's a flawed protagonist
who has the potential for violence
propensity for violence but also like
kind of a kind heart and he's kind of
following a noble mission and so i was
just i was quite attracted to that um as
a central character and then and then
just the world that rural noir world
around him
so so talk about your actors in this um
let's start out with talking about
stephen
um
what was it that made you want to
cast him in this pivotal role of lewis
i was a huge fan of his work in a beale
street um could talk his his uh you know
the which was the follow up on berger
and his follow-up to moonlight
and i was a big fan of his from
homecoming that he did the series with
julia roberts and so
you know uh i was just
i was just like a real fan of his acting
i also thought that these
typically these kind of small town rural
noirs
um
so many of them if you look at hell or
high water or fargo there's so many
great kind of examples they all tend to
be very white uh and and they don't have
a lot of diversity because you know
politically in america you know middle
america is more of a genius obviously in
certain ways and so i was i was
attracted to this idea as well of of
shaking up the genre in different ways
and i didn't want to i didn't want to
make the film necessarily about race
because that you can you know that is a
different movie and there's elements of
that here
but um i also didn't want that to be a
reason why i wouldn't cast someone like
stefan because he typically doesn't sit
you know it's not
these kinds of films typically aren't
written uh for for black actors and so i
was quite excited by that and what it
could bring to the film without
completely steering it in different
directions so there's a lot of reasons
really
so uh
stefan do you pronounce his name stefan
or stephen
stefan
stefan
yeah james
he has to play a character who's
uh has a developmental disability
which
he got from uh an accident where he
almost drowned so like
some brain damage
um which can be
really challenging for actors like
what was it uh
how did you help him
find this character
of lewis yeah well it
it it is it's obviously one of the real
challenges attractions but also things
that that is scary and tricky about a
role like this um
is and so you know the best thing to do
is obviously do research and there's a
like in this day and age there is a
wealth of research that can be done both
online and in person and so
we were able because the symptoms of
kind of traumatic brain injury are often
similar to
um
developmental disabilities on
various ends of the spectrum obviously
sometimes like less serious ends in the
spectrum but it's still it's similar to
those and so you can look at those
uh
symptoms and manifestations on the
spectrum and use that as an analogy even
though it's technically a little
different they they manifest similarly
and so he he kind of used that and spent
some time
um
with some various um
autism groups and and kind of looked at
that and you know to be honest he did a
lot of his own research too like i
guided him but it's one of the things i
like to do i like to give cast a certain
amount of flexibility we hired him early
in the process so he had a long lead up
to to do some research and decide how to
how to approach that set you know
because it's a it's a sensitive thing
obviously to to handle correctly and and
to deal with and so um like i said it
was both a challenge but it was also one
of the scarier things for us just to try
to like get it right
so uh talk about casting paul hauser and
marisa chowmei who are the cops in this
and
with marissa tomei emerging towards the
end as our villain
um
did she enjoy getting to play a villain
role in this film
i think so i think
marissa's typically done certain types
of things and she hasn't often done
something like this and so i find a lot
of the great actors and she's one of
them
like to um
they like to be challenged and try new
things and and it's partly uh
i think what attracted her to this is
that she hadn't really done this before
and people aren't used to seeing her in
this and so
she i think she did quite enjoy just uh
that feel and you know and paul walter
hauser who
you know i've loved him and richard
jewell and i tonya had a bunch of things
and he brings a lighter element even
even when he's playing pretty straight
and so to me he you know he's a nice
spoiled to her it's an interesting match
and it you know it's a serious movie but
i find even serious movies need a
certain amount of levity and paul is
just such a naturalistic brilliant actor
he was such a joy to work with
yeah uh the the differences i i found
those characters the relationship
between them and the developing
relationship between them to be like a
very
uh interesting facet of the movie
uh what about working with travis femmel
who most people know from vikings right
of course yeah
travis was great you know he was in the
stack a role he was kind of you know
in for a week and he had a really busy
week but he he
he really he was fantastic very very
very down to earth and easy to work with
uh brought a great intensity to the role
he's got such strong presence and eyes
and and and focus any and i i feel like
he he doesn't need to try that hard to
kind of get across what we wanted with
stacker in this film which is a man
haunted by some guilt and by some
choices and and uh
and i just found him very believable and
and he was able to kind of bring a lot
of himself to that which is always nice
see you know it's always kind of what
you want as an actor to bring something
strong but not have to like force it and
work too hard and so
um i was really lucky in terms of those
four uh as a as a cast well there's
other there's other great actors
involved too but those were the kind of
the four bigger leads and then there's
janelle williams and hansa hack and some
other great actors too
uh yeah i found i you're you're totally
right his intensity in this
was great and it feels really pivotal to
pushing the story forward you know the
way in which
he's not gonna be
he's obviously found the direction that
he wants to go and he's not going to be
diverted by anybody not wanting him to
tell the truth
and i thought that was pretty beautiful
to witness
um
can you talk about the look of the film
um planning the look of the film with
your dp steve cozzins
yeah
i shot an earlier movie called born navy
blue a jazz bio pic a chet baker jazz
but i picked with steve
um and so we knew each other um
and steve has
is a great natural lighter and we
decided to shoot the film all handheld
steve operates himself um
and so we wanted to give it a like a
looser organic feel and we tried as much
as possible to use existing locations
without like we obviously production
design didn't set deca but we were
trying for quite a naturalistic look
because it's contemporary film
um and i thought steve did a wonderful
job of of of using natural light and not
it's not all natural lighting it's not
like extreme in that sense but
um and just giving us a certain
flexibility with with um with coverage
but also not trying to make it like it's
not like a frenetic fast-paced handheld
film it's still a pretty
quiet slow burn kind of feel but it's
handheld and often steve's handheld is
still very rock-solid so you don't
really want to notice it too much but
you still feel there's something
that's that's moving a little bit um and
then pallet wise i also didn't want to
kind of wash it out and detach it too
much i find like
that can become an overused trope now
and so i wanted to let the film have a
certain vibrancy
uh
and and color and and and i tend to
favor um
kind of wider lenses a lot of close-ups
you know are on some wider lenses so you
feel close to the characters emotionally
like you just as an audience feel close
to them so
um
yeah that was kind of those are some of
the basics of our of our approach to the
film
uh one of the things that i loved was uh
the choice of the song that lewis and
delia sing together ring them golden
bells which
i think we used to sing at my grandma's
church when i would go to church with my
grandma i think we sang this it was so
familiar with me for me yeah it's a
beautiful old song
the version that you chose
to go over the closing credits is by
southern suns but i noticed on spotify
there's hundreds of versions of this
song
why did you pick that one in particular
which i thought was great and i listened
to it several times
yeah i mean i thought the song was great
in that it's got this kind of hopeful
redemptive quality which at the end of
the day is kind of the end goal of
lewis's mission even though it gets dark
and violent and
um i think my editor jeff aschenhurst
even in the assembly had had it pulled
different versions of the song and he
had slapped it in there and then i i
really kind of fell in love with it
because it's it's it's kind of fun and
unique and and the way that some of the
old singers used to kind of harmonize
what they could do with just their
vocals is amazing yeah and so i kind of
i fell in love with that and then you
know to me it was like that song is is a
key motif in the film and then there's
the actual song delia is gone which was
originally by blind willie mctellin was
was covered by bob dylan and johnny cash
and i've always been a huge huge dylan
fan so i i came to this story and song
of delia's gone through bob dylan um
and i know that was also
one of the inspirations from michael
hamlin creating this and and if you look
at songs of that era like there's
delia's gone there's stackerly there's
um
uh i forget i'm i'm uh
i'm i'm blanking on the other one but
all the names of the characters like
louis delia stacker
um
billy lyons those are all characters
from folk songs of the 20s and so
there's this kind of like historic
americana folk song element
uh homage to all the characters and even
the story of of a young black girl being
raped is is what this song julius gone
is about it's based on it it was like
the original song was based on a true
story of a 14 year old black girl who
was raped and that but that you know
this is totally different but there's
still the spirit of that is still in
this story i think
so you've made uh have you made all of
your projects in canada
uh
yeah i mean i've shot i've shot them all
in canada for the most part i've shot
bits and bobs in other countries too but
they've kind of all been canadian based
and
often
use some canadian financing some
government support and then other you
know this typically having american
elements and canadian elements
i'm wondering if um
you've ever thought about the
comparisons but you know between being
an indie filmmaker trying to come up as
a filmmaker in canada versus the us we
ever thought about
i think some people have the perception
that's a bit easier in canada because of
funding for the arts but just wondering
what your thoughts are on that
uh i think in some ways it is easier
because we have more support
i mean it's still hard it's always still
hard to kind of like get the government
money here i know a lot of americans
come up and think it's just like part of
our tax credit you can just get all this
like free canadian money it's actually
really hard and competitive to get it
but
there is there is more opportunity to
get it and i think um what often me what
often happens is um
your your budgets can be a little bit
bigger than they would otherwise be like
i mean i i could make the same you know
my in in the us which is more market
driven you might have to make the same
movie for like two or three million
dollars you can make it for like five in
canada because
you have
30 or 40 or 50 of your budget covered by
some government subsidy and so that's i
think that's one of the differences is i
still i do feel quite lucky on that
front in that
we have the support but that being said
a lot of my movies are still pretty cast
driven which still means that to do them
on the level i i still need a certain
amount of um
they can't just be pure
government-supported movies they have to
have pretty strong american elements too
uh and or their
you know international co-productions a
lot of my past movies were canada
and europe or are just various
co-productions because then it allows
you more
cast flexibility because sometimes if
you're just making pure canadian movies
there's a lot of rules around
how many kittens you can cast how many
cans you can have and that can become a
little restricting um
and so
but i i think it is probably a little
easier it's a nice advantage to have
well so the film comes out
this friday
august 19th is that this friday already
oh perhaps that's next week
that's eight days
um it's soon though it's coming yeah
august 19th uh is it gonna be in
theaters and streaming or just theaters
in the beginning
this theaters is the plan in the in the
beginning and then uh
follow up on on streaming yeah
well congratulations on on a great film
uh we wish you the best of luck with it
and thank you so much for coming to talk
with us today
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]